So my name is Erik Demaine. You should
call me Erik. Welcome back to 6.046. This
is Lecture 2. And today we are going to essentially
fill in some of the more mathematical underpinnings
of Lecture 1. So, Lecture 1, we just sort
of barely got our feet wet with some analysis
of algorithms, insertion sort and mergesort.
And we needed a couple of tools. We had this
big idea of asymptotics and forgetting about
constants, just looking at the lead term.
And so, today, we're going to develop asymptotic
notation so that we know that mathematically.
And we also ended up with a recurrence with
mergesort, the running time of mergesort,
so we need to see how to solve recurrences.
And we will do those two things today. Question?
Yes, I will speak louder. Thanks. Good. Even
though I have a microphone, I am not amplified.
OK, so let's start with asymptotic notation.
We have seen some basic asymptotic notation.
I am sure you have seen it in other classes
before, things like big O-notation. And today
we are going to really define this rigorously
so we know what is true and what is not, what
is valid and what is not. We are going to
define, and unfortunately today is going to be really mathematical
and really no algorithms today, which is sort
of an anticlimax. But next lecture we will
talk about real algorithms and will apply
all the things we learned today to real algorithms.
This is big O-notation, capital O-notation.
We have f(n)=O[g(n)]. This means that there
are some suitable constants, c and n_o, such
that f is bounded by cg(n) for all sufficiently
large n. So, this is pretty intuitive notion.
We have seen it before. We are going to assume
that f(n) is non-negative here. And I just
want f(n) to be bounded above by g(n). We
have seen a bunch of examples, but something
like 2n^2=O(n^3) defined. And roughly this
means if you drop leading constants and low
order terms then this is less than or equal
to that. So, big O corresponds roughly to
less than or equal to. But this is the formalization.
Another way to think of it formally, a funny
thing about this notation is it is asymmetric.
Normally, you think of equality being symmetric.
If A=B then B=A. But it's not true here. We
do not have n^3 being big O of n^2. We don't
even have big O of n^3 equaling n^2. So, we
will see exactly what that means in a second.
But before we get there, this is a bit bizarre
notation and you should always think about
what it really means. Another way to think
about what it really means is that f(n) is
in some set of functions that are like g.
You could define big O[g(n)] to be a set of
functions, let's call it f(n), such that there
exist constants. They are the same definition,
I think, fancy here, c and n_o, such that
we have the bound f(n) is between zero and
cg(n). It is a bit of a long definition, and
that is why we use the notation, to avoid
having to write this over and over. You can
think of instead of n^2 being equal to big
O of n^3, what we really mean is that 2n^2
is in the set big O(n^3). When we write equal
sign, we in some sense mean this in the set,
but we are going to use equal sign. You could
write this. And occasionally you see papers
that write this, but this is the notation
that we are going to use. That has the consequence
the equal sign is asymmetric, just like this
operator. We have some nifty ways that we
actually use big O-notation. And it is using
it as a macro. By the way, we have a lot to
cover today, so I am going to go relatively
fast. If anything is unclear, just stop, ask
questions, then I will slow down. Otherwise,
I will take this as all completely obvious
and I can keep going at full speed. The convention,
this is intuitive, I guess, if you do some
macro programming or something, but it's a
bit more mathematical. We have defined big
O-notation and it equals big O of something.
And so we have only defined big O when on
the equal sign we have big O of some function.
But it is useful to have some general expression
on the right-hand side that involves big O.
For example, let's say we have f(n) = n^3
+ O(n^2). This is attempting to get an error
bound. This is saying f(n) is basically n^3
but there are these lower order terms that
are O(n^2). And so this means that there is
a function, shorthand for a function, h(n)
which is in O(n^2) or equals O(n^2) such that
f(n) = n^3 + h(n). It is saying that there
are some lower order terms that are bounded
above by some constant times n^2 for sufficiently
large n, and that is what is here. And then
f(n) equals, now this is a true equality,
n^3 plus that error term. This is very useful
here. Essentially, I am expressing what the
lead constant is and then saying well, there
is other stuff and it's all at most n^2. Saying
that f(n) therefore is also order n^3, but
that is a bit weaker of a statement. This
is a bit more refined. We won't need to use
this too often, but it is useful. Sometimes
we will see, like in last class we even had
a big O inside a summation. So, you can use
them all over the place. The point is they
represent some function in that set. A bit
less intuitive, and this is more subtle, is
what it means to have big O on the left-hand
side. It means the same thing, but there is
some convention what equality means. And this
is why equal sign is asymmetric. You should
read equals like "is". Is means that everything
over here is something over here. So, there
is an implicit for all on the left-hand side
and there exists on the right-hand side. This
is a true statement. Anything that is n^2
+ O(n) is also O(n^2), but not the other way
around. So, this is a bit asymmetric. If you
think about it, this is pretty intuitive but
it is subtle so you should be careful. This
says for any expansion of the macro on the
left-hand side, which should be f(n), there
is an expansion of the macro on the right-hand
side such that we get equality. And what this
allows you to do is if you have a chain of
equal signs relations, a chain of "is"s, then
the very first one is equal to or bounded
by the very last one. So, you can chain equal
signs the way you normally would. You just
cannot flip them around. Good. So, that's
big O-notation. Any questions about that?
So, big O is great for expressing upper bounds.
But we also want to talk about lower bounds.
For algorithms, we usually care about upper
bounds on their running time. Running times
at most n^2 is at most n log n up to big O,
but sometimes we need to express functions
that are at least some quantity. For example,
we will show that sorting requires at least
n log n time in some model. So, we need some
other notation for that. And the notation
is big Omega-notation. And it is pretty symmetric.
I will just write out the set definition here.
And we are going to write f(n)= big Omega[g(n)]
to mean f(n) is at least some constant times
g(n) -- -- for sufficiently large n. So, I
am basically just reversing the inequality
relation between f and g, nothing surprising,
just to have it there. A random example, and
now we will get a little bit more sophisticated,
root n= big Omega(lg n). And you should read
this that up to constant factors root n is
at least log n for sufficiently large n. So,
omega sort of corresponds to greater than
or equal to. Let me give you some analogies.
We have big O, we have big omega, this is
less than or equal to, this is greater than
or equal to. And I am going to fill in some
more here in a moment. It's nice to have all
the usual operators we have. Normally we have
strict less than, strict greater than and
equal sign. And we want those sort of analogs
in the asymptotic world where we ignore constant
factors and ignore lower order terms. We have,
for example, big Theta[g(n)]. This is a capital
theta which means you write the horizontal
bar in the middle as opposed to all the way
through. I didn't invent Greek, so that is
the way it is. Theta means that you are less
than or equal to and you are greater than
or equal to up to constant factors, so it
is the inner section of these two sets, big
O and big Omega. That is sort of like equal
sign but, of course, this is very different.
You have things like n^2 is big Theta of 2(n^2)
because you ignore constant factors, but all
of these other relations, OK, n^2 + O(n) = Theta(n^2),
but this does not hold with theta because
square root of n is really asymptotically
bigger than log n. And some of the other examples
we saw like n^2 versus n^3, those don't hold
with T. And we have some strict notation which
are the little o-notation and little omega-notation.
There is no little theta because there is
not notion of strict equality versus unstrict
equality. Little o is going to correspond
roughly to less than and little omega is going
to correspond to greater than. This is a notation
you will just have to get used to. And I am
not going to define it precisely here because
it is almost exactly the same. The difference
is that instead of saying there exists constant
c and n_o, you have to say for every constant
c there exists a constant n_o. The relationship
between f and g, this inequality must hold
for all c instead of just for 1. And so n_o
can now depend on c. You can assume that really
n is sufficiently large, but this gives you
a strict inequality. No matter what constant
you put here, in front of g, let's say we
are doing little o, f will be still less than
c times g for sufficiently large n. We have
some random examples. We are again ignoring
constants. n^2 is always less than n^3 for
sufficiently large n. And it is a bit subtle
here. I mean in order to prove something like
this, it will become intuitive after you manipulate
it a little bit. You have to figure out what
n_o is in terms of c. I think it something
like 2/c. If we have less than or equal to,
that should be right. As long n is at least
this big, no matter how small of a c, you
should think of c here as being epsilon now,
in the usual epsilon and deltas. No matter
how small c gets, still I can bound n^2 in
terms of n^3, upper bound, but whenever you
have theta you do not have either of these
relations. For example, Ωn^2 = Theta(n^2)
and it is not little o(n^2) and it not little
omega(n^2) because it is exactly n^2. You
will get some sense in order relation out
of this, although there are some messy behaviors
as you will see in your problem set. Any questions
about asymptotic notation? That is the quick
rundown. Now we are going to use it to solve
some recurrences. Although we won't use it
that much today, we will use it a lot more
on Wednesday. OK. We will move onto the second
topic of today, which is solving recurrences.
You have probably solved some recurrences
before in 6.042 or whatever discrete math
class you have taken. We are going to do more
and have some techniques here that are particularly
useful for analyzing recursive algorithms,
and we will see that mostly on Wednesday.
There are three main methods that we are going
to use here for solving recurrences. The first
one is the substitution method. There is no
general procedure for solving a recurrence.
There is no good algorithm for solving recurrences,
unfortunately. We just have a bunch of techniques.
Some of them work some of the time, and if
you are lucky yours will work for your recurrence,
but it is sort of like solving an integral.
You have to just know some of them, you have
to know various methods for solving them.
It is usually easy to check if you have the
right answer. Just like with integrals, you
just differentiate and say oh, I got the right
answer. And that is essentially the idea of
substitution method. Substitution method will
always work, but unfortunately Step 1 is guess
the answer. And you have to guess it correctly.
That makes it a big difficult. You don't have
to guess it completely. You can usually get
away with not knowing the constant factors,
which is a good thing because we don't really
care about the constant factors. You guess
the form. You say oh, it is going to be roughly
n^2, and so it's some constant times n^2 presumably.
So, you guess that. We are going to figure
out the constants. You try to verify whether
the recurrence satisfies this bound by induction,
and that is the key. Substitution uses induction.
And from that you usually get the constants
for free. You figure out what the constants
have to be in order to make this work. So,
that is the general idea. You will see a few
examples of this. Actually, the same example
several times. Unfortunately, this is what
you might call, I don't know. This is an algorithm,
but it uses an oracle which is knowing the
right answer. But sometimes it is not too
hard to guess the answer. It depends. If you
look at this recurrence, T(n) = 4T(n/2) +
n, we should implicitly always have some base
case of T of some constant, usually 1 is a
constant, so we don't really care about the
base case. For algorithms that is always the
case. And we want to solve this thing. Does
anyone have a guess to what the solution is?
Ideally someone who doesn't already know how
to solve this recurrence. OK. How many people
know how to solve this recurrence? A few,
OK. And, of the rest, any guesses? If you
look at what is going on here, here you have
T(n/2) and let's ignore this term more or
less. We have n/2 here. If we double n and
get T(n) then we multiply the value by 4.
And then there is this additive end, but that
doesn't matter so much. What function do you
know that when you double the argument the
output goes up by a factor of 4? Sorry? n^2,yeah.
You should think n^2 and you would be right.
But we won't prove n^2 yet. Let's prove something
simpler, because it turns out proving that
it is at most n^2 is a bit of a pain. We will
see that in just a few minutes. But let's
guess that T(n) = O(n^3) first because that
will be easier to prove by induction. You
sort of see how it is done in the easy case,
and then we will actually get the right answer,
n^2, later. I need to prove. What I am going
to do is guess that T(n) is some constant
times n^3 at most, so I will be a little more
precise. I cannot use the big O-notation in
the substitution method so I have to expand
it out to use constants. I will show you why
in a little bit, but let me just tell you
at a high level what is important in not using
big O-notation. Big O-notation is great if
you have a finite chain of big O relations,
you know, n^2 is big O(n^3) is big O(n^4)
is big O(n^4) is big O(n^4). That is all true.
And so you get that n^2 is big O(n^4). But
if you have an infinite chain of those relations
then the first thing is not big O of the last
thing. You have to be very careful. For example,
this is a total aside on the lecture notes.
Suppose you want to prove that n = O(1). This
is a great relation. If it were true, every
algorithm would have constant running time.
This is not true. Not in Wayne's World notation.
You could "prove this by induction" by saying
well, base case is 1 = O(1). OK, that is true.
And then the induction step as well, if I
know that n-1, so let's suppose that n-1 = O(1),
well, that implies that n, which is (n-1)
+1, if this is O(1) and 1 = O(1), the whole
thing is O(1). And that is true. If you knew
that (n-1) = O(1) and 1 = O(1) then their
sum is also O(1), but this is a false proof.
You cannot induct over big Os. What is going
on here is that the constants that are implicit
in here are changing. Here you have some big
O of 1, here you have some big O of 1. You
are probably doubling the constant in there
every time you do this relation. If you have
a finite number of doubling of constants,
no big deal, it is just a constant, two the
power number of doublings. But here you are
doing n doublings and that is no good. The
constant is now depending on n. So, we are
avoiding this kind of problem by writing out
the constant. We have to make sure that constant
doesn't change. Good. Now I have written out
the constant. I should be safe. I am assuming
it for all k less than n, now I have to prove
it for k equal to n. I am going to take T(n)
and just expand it. I am going to do the obvious
thing. I have this recurrence how to expand
T(n). Then it involves T(n/2). And I know
some fact about T(n/2) because n/2 is less
than n. So, let's expand. T(n) = 4T(n/2) +
n. And now I have an upper bound on this thing
from the induction hypothesis. This is at
most 4 times c times the argument cubed plus
n.
Continuing on here. Let's expand this a little
bit. We have n cubed over 2 cubed. Two cubed
is 8, so 4 over 8 is a half. So, we have Ωcn^3
+ n. And what I would like this to be is,
so at the bottom where I would like to go
is that this is at most cn3. That is what
I would like to prove to reestablish the induction
hypothesis for n. What I will do, in order
to see when that is case, is just write this
as what I want, so this is sort of the desired
value, cn3, minus whatever I don't want. This
is called the residual. Now I have to actually
figure this out. Let's see. We have cn^3,
but only Ωcn^3 here, so I need to subtract
off Ωcn^3 to get that lead term correct.
And then I have plus n and there is a minus
here, so it is minus n. And that is the residual.
In order for this to be at most this, I need
that the residual is non-negative. This is
if the residual part is greater than or equal
to zero, which is pretty easy to do because
here I have control over c. I get to pick
c to be whatever I want. And, as long as c
is at least, oh, I don't know, 2, then this
is a 1 at least. Then I have n^3 should be
greater than or equal to n. And that is always
the case. For example, this is true if c is
at least what n is, but let's say n is at
least 1 just for kicks. So, what we have done
is proved that T(n) is at most some constant
times n^3. And the constant is like 1. So,
that is an upper bound. It is not a tight
upper bound. We actually believed that it
is n^2, and it is, but you have to be a little
careful. This does not mean that the answer
is n^3. It just means that at most n^3 is
big O(n^3). And this is a proof by induction.
Now, technically I should have put a base
case in this induction, so there is a little
bit missing. The base case is pretty easy
because T(1) is some constant, but it will
sort of influence things. If the base case
T(1) is some constant. And what we need is
that it is at most c times one cubed, which
is c. And that will be true as long as you
choose c to be sufficiently large. So, this
is true if c is chosen sufficiently large.
Now, we don't care about constants, but the
point is just to be a little bit careful.
It is not true that T(n) is at most 1 times
n^2, even though here all we need is that
c is at least 1. For the base case to work,
c actually might have to be a hundred or whatever
T(1) is. So, be a little bit careful there.
It doesn't really affect the answer, usually
it won't because we have very simple base
cases here. OK, so let's try to prove the
tight bound of O(n^2). I am not going to prove
an omega bound, but you can prove an omega
n squared bound as well using substitution
method. I will just be satisfied for now proving
an upper bound of n squared. Let's try to
prove that T(n), this is the same recurrence,
I want to prove that it is O(n^2). I am going
to do the same thing. And I will write a bit
faster because this is basically copying.
Except now, instead of three, I have two.
Then I have T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n. I expand this
T(n/2). This is at most 4c(n/2)^2 + n. And
now, instead of have 2 cubed, I have 2 squared,
which is only 4. The fours cancel. I get cn^2
+ n. And if you prefer to write it as desired
minus residual, then I have cn^2 - (-n). And
I want this to be non-negative. And it is
damn hard for minus n to be non-negative.
If n is zero we are happy, but unfortunately
this is an induction on n. It's got to hold
for all n greater than or equal to 1. This
is not less than or equal to cn^2. Notice
the temptation is to write that this equals
O(n^2), which is true for this one step. cn^2
- (-n), well, these are both order n, or this
is order n, this is order n squared. Certainly
this thing is O(n^2), that is true, but it
is not completing the induction. To complete
the induction, you have to prove the induction
hypothesis for n with this constant c. Here
you are getting a constant c of like c + 1,
which is not good. This is true but useless.
It does not finish the induction, so you can
sort of ignore that. This proof doesn't work,
which is kind of annoying because we feel,
in our heart of hearts, that T(n) = n^2. It
turns out to fix this you need to express
T(n) in a slightly different form. This is,
again, divine inspiration. And, if you have
a good connection to some divinity, you are
all set. [LAUGHTER] But it is a little bit
harder for the rest of us mere mortals. It
turns out, and maybe you could guess this,
that the idea is we want to strengthen the
induction hypothesis. We assumed this relatively
weak thing, T(k) is less than or equal to
some constant times k^2. We didn't know what
the constant was, that is fine, but we assumed
that there were no lower order terms. I want
to look at lower order terms. Maybe they play
a role. And if you look at this progression
you say, oh, well, I am getting something
like n^2 and the constants are pretty damn
tight. I mean the fours are canceling and
the c just is preserved. How am I going to
get rid of this lower order term plus n? Well,
maybe I could subtract off a linear term in
here and, if I am lucky, it will cancel with
this one. That is all the intuition we have
at this point. It turns out it works. We look
at T(n) and this is 4T(n/2) + n as usual.
Now we expand a slightly messier form. We
have 4[c_1*(n/2)^2 - c_2*(n/2)] + n. This
part is the same because the fours cancel
again. So, we get c_1*n^2, which is good.
I mean that is sort of the form we want. Then
we have something times n, so let's figure
it out. We have a plus 1 times n, so let's
write it 1 minus c_2 over 2 times n. Oops,
got that wrong. There is four times a two
so, in fact, the two is upstairs. Let me double
check. Right. OK. Now we can write this as
desired minus residual. And we have to be
a little careful here because now we have
a stronger induction hypothesis to prove.
We don't just need it is at most c_1*n^2,
which would be fine here because we could
choose c_2 to be large, but what we really
need is c_1*n^2 - c_2*n, and then minus some
other stuff. This is, again, desired minus
residual. And minus residual, let's see, we
have a minus 1 and we have a minus c_2. That
doesn't look so happy. Plus c_2, thank you,
because that again looked awfully negative.
It is plus c_2. I am getting my signs, there
is a minus here and there is one minus here,
so there we go. Again, I want my residual
to be greater than or equal to zero. And if
I have that I will be all set in making this
inductive argument. Office hours start this
week, in case you are eager to go. They are
all held in some room in Building 24, which
is roughly the midpoint between here and Stata,
I think, for no particular reason. And you
can look at the Web page for details on the
office hours. Continuing along, when is c_2
- 1 going to be greater than or equal to zero?
Well, that is true if c_2 is at least 1, which
is no big deal. Again, we get to choose the
constants however we want. It only has to
hold for some choice of constants. So, we
can set c_2 greater than or equal to 1. And
then we are happy. That means this whole thing
is less than or equal to c_1*n^2 - c_2*n if
c_2 is greater than or equal to 1. It is kind
of funny here. This finishes the induction,
at least the induction step. We proved now
that for any value of c_1, and provided c_2
is at least one. We have to be a little more
careful that c_1 does actually have to be
sufficiently large. Any particular reason
why? c_1 better not be negative, indeed. c_1
has to be positive for this to work, but it
even has to be larger than positive depending.
Sorry. I have been going so fast, I haven't
asked you questions. Now you are caught off
guard. Yeah? Because of the base case, exactly.
So, the base case will have T(1) is c_1 time
1 squared minus c_2, we want to prove that
it is at most this, and T(1) is some constant
we have assumed. We need to choose c_1 to
be sufficiently larger than c_2, in fact,
so c_2 has to be at least 1. c_1 may have
to be at least a hundred more than one if
this is sufficiently large. And sufficiently
large now means with respect to c_2. You have
to be a little bit careful, but in this case
it doesn't matter. Any questions about the
substitution method? That was the same example
three times. In the end, it turned out we
got the right answer. But we sort of had to
know the answer in order to find it, which
is a bit of a pain. It would certainly be
nicer to just figure out the answer by some
procedure, and that will be the next two techniques
we talk about. Sorry? How would you prove
a lower bound? I haven't tried it for this
recurrence, but you should be able to do exactly
the same form. Argue that T(n) is greater
than or equal to c_1*n^2 - c_2*n. I didn't
check whether that particular form will work,
but I think it does. Try it. These other methods
will give you, in some sense, upper and lower
bounds if you are a little bit careful. But,
to really check things, you pretty much have
to do the substitution method. And you will
get some practice with that. Usually we only
care about upper bounds. Proving upper bounds
like this is what we will focus on, but occasionally
we need lower bounds. It is always nice to
know that you have the right answer by proving
a matching lower bound. The next method we
will talk about is the recursion-tree method.
And it is a particular way of adding up a
recurrence, and it is my favorite way. It
usually just works. That's the great thing
about it. It provides you intuition for free.
It tells you what the answer is pretty much.
It is slightly nonrigorous, this is a bit
of a pain, so you have to be really careful
when you apply it. Otherwise, you might get
the wrong answer. Because it involves dot,
dot, dots, our favorite three characters,
but dot, dot, dots are always a little bit
nonrigorous so be careful. Technically, what
you should do is find out what the answer
is with recursion-tree method. Then prove
that it is actually right with the substitution
method. Usually that is not necessary, but
you should at least have in your mind that
that is required rigorously. And probably
the first few recurrences you solve, you should
do it that way. When you really understand
the recursion-tree method, you can be a little
bit more sloppy if you are really sure you
have the right answer. Let's do an example.
We saw recursion trees very briefly last time
with mergesort as the intuition why it was
n log n. And, if you took an example like
the one we just did with the recursion-tree
method, it is dead simple. Just to make our
life harder, let's do a more complicated recursion.
Here we imagine we have some algorithm. It
starts with a problem size n, it recursively
solves a problem of size n/4, it then recursively
solves a problem of size n/2, and it does
n^2 work on the side without nonrecursive
work. What is that? I mean that is a bit less
obvious, I would say. What we are going to
do is draw a picture, and we are just going
to expand out that recursion in tree form
-- --
and then just add everything up. We want the
general picture, and the general principle
in the recursion-tree method is we just draw
this as a picture. We say well, T(n) equals
the sum of n^2, T(n/4) and T(n/2). This is
a weird way of writing a sum but why not write
it that way. This is going to be a tree. And
it is going to be a tree by recursively expanding
each of these two leaves. I start by expanding
T(n) to this, then I keep expanding, expanding,
expanding everything. Let's go one more step.
We have this n^2, T(n/4), T(n/2). If we expand
one more time, this is going to be n^2 plus
two things. The first thing is going to be
(n/4)^2, the second thing is going to be (n/2)^2.
Plus their recursive branches. We have T(n/16)
and T(n/8). Here my arithmetic shows thin.
This better be the same, T(n/8), and this
should be T(n/4), I believe. You just keep
going forever, I mean, until you get down
to the base case where T is a constant. So,
I am now going to skip some steps and say
dot, dot, dot. This is where you have to be
careful. We have n^2, (n/4)^2, (n/2)^2. Now
this is easy because I have already done them
all. (n/16)^2, (n/8)^2, (n/8)^2 again, (n/4)^2
and et cetera, dot, dot, dot, of various levels
of recursion here. At the bottom, we are going
to get a bunch of constants. These are the
leaves. I would like to know how many leaves
there are. One challenge is how many leaves
in this tree could there be? This is a bit
subtle, unlike mergesort or unlike the previous
recurrence we solved, the number of leaves
here is a bit funny because we are recursing
at different speeds. This tree is going to
be much smaller than this tree. It is going
to have smaller depth because it has already
done down to (n/16). Here it has only gone
down to (n/4). But how many leaves are there
in this recursion tree? All I need is an upper
bound, some reasonable upper bound. I can
tell you it is at most T(n^10), but that is
a bit unreasonable. It should be less than
n, good. Why is it less than n? Exactly. I
start with a problem of size n. And I recurse
into a problem that n/4 and a problem that
says n/2. When I get down to one I stop. So,
n/4 + n/2 = æn, which is strictly less than
n. So, definitely the total number of leaves
has to be at most n. If I start out with n
sort of stuff and get rid of a quarter of
it and then recurse, it is definitely going
to be less than n stuff at the bottom. So,
strictly less than n leaves. At this point,
I have done nothing interesting. And then
the second cool idea in recursion trees is
you don't just expand this tree and see what
it looks like and then say, well, God, how
the hell am I going to sum that? You sum it
level by level. That is the only other idea.
It usually works really, really well. Here
it is a bit complicated and I have to think
a bit to figure out n^2 is n^2. That is the
first level. Easy. The second level, I have
to think a lot harder. There are three kinds
of mathematicians, those who can add and those
who cannot, and I am the latter kind so I
need your help. Can you add these things together?
It's n^2 over something. Please? (5/16)n^2.
Now I really need your help. I think that
one I could have done, but this one is a little
bit harder. I will go look at my notes while
you compute that. Any answers? 73/256. Anyone
else confirm that? It seems a bit high to
me. 73 does not sound right to me. 64? Closer.
It is actually important that we get this
right. The 256 is correct. I can tell. Everyone
should know that 16^2 = 256. We are computer
scientists. 25, good. We have two people saying
25, therefore it is correct by democracy.
[LAUGHTER] 25 is also what my notes say, and
I computed it at home. (25/256)n^2 is the
right answer. Now, did anyone notice something
magical about this progression? It squares
each time, good. And, if we were going to
add these up, you might call it? A geometric
series, very good. So, it turns out this is
geometric. And we know how to sum geometric
series, at least you should. We started n^2.
We know that at the bottom, well, this is
not quite a level, we get something like n,
but we are decreasing geometrically. So, the
total, I mean the solution to the recurrence
is the sum of all the numbers in this tree.
If we added it up level by level and then
add up all the levels that is going to give
us the answer. This is the total computed
level by level. It is just a cute way to compute
it. It usually gives you nice answers like
geometric answers. We have n^2(1 + 5/16 +
25/256 + ...). And, if we believe in fate
and we see this three number recurrence, we
know that we have the right answer. In general,
it is going to be (5/16)k, at least we hope,
and so on. And it keeps going. It doesn't
go on infinitely, but let's just assume it
goes on infinitely. That will be an upper
bound that goes on forever. This is all times
n^2. Now, if you are going to know one thing
about geometric series, you should know that
1 + Ω + º, if you sum all the powers of
2 you get 2. We are computer scientists. We
have got to know at least the binary case.
This is like writing 0.1111111 in binary,
actually, as 1, so this is 2. This is even
smaller. We have 5/16, that is less than a
half and then we are squaring each time, so
this is even less than 2. If you want, there
is a nifty formula for solving the general
geometric series, but all we need is that
it is a constant. This is O(n^2). It is also
O(n^2). It is pretty obvious that it is O(n^2)
because the top thing is n^2. So, there is
our lower bound of n^2. And we have it within
a factor of 2, which is pretty good. You actually
get a better factor here. So, that is recursion-tree
method. It is a little shaky here because
we have these dot, dot, dots, and we just
believe that it is geometric. It turns out
most of the time it is geometric. No problem
here. I would definitely check it with the
substitution method because this is not obvious
to me that it is going to be geometric. In
the cases we will look at in a moment, it
will be much clearer, so clear that we can
state a theorem that everything is working
fine. And still time, good. So, that was recursion-trees.
There is one more method we are going to talk
about, and you could essentially think of
it as an application of the recursion-tree
method but it is made more precise. And it
is an actual theorem, whereas recursion trees,
if the dot, dot, dots aren't obvious, you
better check them. The sad part about the
master method is it is pretty restrictive.
It only applies to a particular family of
recurrences. It should be T(n) = aT(n/b) +
f(n). Am I going to
call it f? Yes, I will call it f. In particular,
it will not cover the recurrence I just solved
because I was recursing on two different problems
of different sizes. Here, every problem you
recurse on should be of the same size. There
are a subproblems. A way to think of this
is a recursive algorithm. You have a subproblems.
Each of them is of size n/b, so the total
costs will be this. Then you are doing f(n)
nonrecursive work. A few constraints. a should
be at least 1, should have at least 1 recursion.
b should be strictly greater than 1. You better
make the problem smaller or else it is going
to be infinity. And f should have some nice
property. f(n) should be asymptotically positive.
How many people know what asymptotically positive
means? No one. OK, you haven't read the textbook.
That's OK. I haven't read it either, although
don't tell Charles. And he'd notice. And what
might you think asymptotically positive means?
That we can do a little bit better. Sorry?
Yes, it means for large enough n, f(n) is
positive. This means f(n) is greater than
zero for n, at least some n_o, so for some
constant n_o. Eventually it should be positive.
I mean, we don't care about whether it's negative
1 for n=1, not a big deal. It won't affect
the answer because we only care about the
asympotics within. The master method, you
gave it a recurrence of this form, it tells
you the answer. That is the great thing about
the master method. The annoying thing about
the master method is that it has three cases.
It is a big long. It takes a little bit longer
to memorize than all the others because the
others are just ideas. Here we need to actually
remember a few things. Let me state the theorem.
Well, not quite yet. There is one very simple
idea, which is we are going to compare this
nonrecursive work f(n) with a very particular
function n^(log_b(a)). Why n^(log_b(a))? You
will see later. It turns out it is the number
of leaves in the recursion tree, but that
is foreshadowing. So, it is either less, equal
or bigger. And here we care about asymptotics.
And we have to be a little bit more precious
about less, equal or bigger. You might think
well, it means little o, big Theta, or little
omega. It would be nice if the theorem held
for all of those cases, but it leaves some
gaps. Let's start with Case 1. Case 1 is when
f is smaller. And not just that it is little
o, but it is actually quite a bit smaller.
It has got to be polynomially smaller than
n^(log_b(a)). For some positive epsilon, the
running time should be this n to this constant
log base b of a minus that epsilon, so it
is really polynomially smaller than n^(log_b(a)).
We cannot handle the little o case, that's
a little bit too strong. This is saying it
is really quite a bit smaller. But the answer
then is really simple, T(n) = Theta(n^(log_b(a))).
Great. That is
Case 1. Case 2 is when f(n) is pretty much
equal to n^(log_b(a)). And by pretty much
equal I mean up to poly log factors. This
is log base 2 of n to the power k. You should
know this notation. For example, k could be
zero. And then they are equal up to constant
factors, for some k greater than or equal
to zero. Less than will not work, so it is
really important that k is non-negative. It
should probably be an integer. It doesn't
actually matter whether there is an integer,
but there it is. It could n^(log_b(a)) times
log n or just times nothing, whatever. Again,
the solution is easy here, T(n) = Theta(n^(log_b(a))*
lg^(k+1)(n)). Presumably it has to be at least
times log k. It turns out it is log to the
k plus 1 of n. That is Case 2. We have one
more case which is slightly more complicated.
We need to assume slightly more for Case 3.
But Case 3 is roughly when f(n) grows bigger
than n^(log_b(a)). So, it should be capital
Omega, here is one place where we get to use
omega, (n^(log_b(a)) + epsilon) for some positive
epsilon. It should grow not just bigger but
polynomially bigger. Here it was growing just
a log factor bigger, poly log, and here it
is a polynomial factor. In this case, we need
another assumption about f because we worry
a little bit about how quickly f grows. We
want to make sure that as you go down the
recursion f gets smaller. It would be kind
of nice if f gets smaller as you go down,
otherwise you are, again, trying to sum to
infinity or whatever. I see why this is for
some epsilon prime greater than zero. What
I would like is that if I just sort of take
the recurrence, this T(n) and just throw in
fs instead, f(n) should be somehow related
to af(n/b). What I would like is that f(n),
which is at the top of the recursion tree,
should be bigger than the thing at the next
level down. The sum of all the values at the
next level down should be bigger by some constant
factor. Here I have the next level down is
at most some 1 - e, something strictly less
than 1, some constant strictly less than 1
times the thing at the top level. I need that
to make sure things are getting smaller as
I go down. Then T(n) = Theta[f(n)]. And that
is the theorem. This is the master theorem
or whatever you want to call it. It is not
named after some guy name Master. It is just
the master of all methods because it is very
easy to apply. Let's apply it a few times.
It is a bit much to take in all at once. And
then I will give you a sketch of the proof
to see that it is really not that surprising
this is true if you look at the recursion-tree.
But first let's just try using it. For example,
we could take T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n. This is
a, this is b, this is f(n). The first thing
we should compute is n^(log_b(a)). This I
think even I can do. Log base 2 of 4. Yeah,
log base 2 I can do. This is n^2. OK, so is
f(n) smaller or bigger than n^2? Well, f(n)
= n. n^2 is clearly bigger by a polynomial
factor. So, we are in Case 1. What is the
answer? n^2, yeah. It is T(n^(log_b(a))),
which here it is just n^2. Let's do some slight
variation. I am going to keep a and b the
same and just change f. Let's say T(n) = 4T(n/2)
+ n^2. This is like drill spelling. n^2 is
asymptotically the same as n^2 even up to
constants. What is the answer? This is Case
2. It is slightly harder. What is k in this
example? Zero. The answer is? Survey says?
n^2 log n. Good. And a couple more. T(n) = 4T(n/2)
+ n^3. What is the answer? n^3. This is Case
3. I know this is pretty boring. At this point
we are just applying this stupid theorem.
How about n^2/lg n? What is the answer? Good.
In this case no one should answer. It is a
big tricky. I forget exactly the answer. I
think it is like n^2 log log n over log n,
no? Oh, no. n^2 log log n, that's right. Yeah.
But you shouldn't know that, and this doesn't
follow from the master method. This is something
you would have to solve, probably with the
recursion-tree would be a good way to do this
one, and you need to know some properties
of logs to know how that goes. But here the
master method does not apply. And so you have
to use a different method. OK. The last thing
I want to do is tell you why the master method
is true, and that makes it much more intuitive,
especially using recursion-trees, why everything
works. This is a sketch of a proof, not the
full thing. You should read the proof in the
textbook. It is not that much harder than
what I will show, but it is good for you to
know the formal details. I don't have time
here to do all of the details. I will just
tell you the salient parts. This is the proof
sketch or the intuition behind the master
method. What we are going to do is just take
the recursion-tree for this recurrence and
add up each level and then add up all the
levels and see what we get. We start with
f(n) at the top after we have expanded one
level. Then we get a different problems, each
of n/b. And after we expand them it will f(n/b)
for each one. They are all the same size.
Then we expand all of those and so on, and
we get another a subproblems from there. We
are going to get like f((n/b)^2). That is
sort of decreasing geometrically the size,
and so on and so on and so on, until at the
bottom we get constant size problems. This
is a bit special because this is the base
case, but we have some other constant at the
bottom. We would like to know how many leaves
there are, but that is a little bit tricky
at the moment. Let's first compute the height
of this tree. Let me draw it over here. What
is the height of this tree? I start with a
problem of size n. I want to get down to a
problem of size 1. How long does that take?
How many levels? This is probably too easy
for some and not at your fingertips for others.
Log base b of n, good. The height of this
tree is n^(log_b(a)), because it is just how
many times I divide by b until I get down
to 1. That is great. Now I should be able
to compute the number of leaves because I
have branching factor a, I have height h.
The number of leaves is a^h, a^log_b(n). Let
me expand that a little bit. a^log_b(n), properties
of logs, we can take the n downstairs and
put the a upstairs, and we get n^(log_b(a)).
Our good friend n^(log_b(a)). So, that is
why Our good friend n^(log_b(a)) is so important
in the master method. What we are doing is
comparing f, which is the top level, to n^(log_b(a)),
which up to theta is the bottom level. Now
the leaves are all at the same level because
we are decreasing at the same rate in every
branch. If I add up the cost at the bottom
level, it is Theta(n^(log_b(a))). I add up
the things at the top level it is f(n), not
terribly exciting. But the next level, this
is a little bit more interesting, is af(n/b),
which should look familiar if you had the
master method already memorized, it is that.
So, we know that af(n/b) has decreased by
some constant factor, 1-epsilon prime. We
have gone down. This is a constant factor
smaller than this. And then you sum up the
next level. It is going to be like a^2f(n/b^2).
I see that I actually wrote this wrong, the
parentheses. Sorry about that. It is not (n/b)^2.
It is (n/b^2). So, this sequence, in Case
3 at least, is decreasing geometrically. If
it is decreasing geometrically up to constant
factors, it is dominated by the biggest term,
which is f(n). Therefore, in Case 3, we get
Theta[f(n)]. Let's look at the other cases,
and let me adapt those cases to how much time
we have left. Wow, lot's of time. Five minutes.
Tons of time. What to do? Let me write that
down. Case 3, the costs decrease. Now, this
is a place I would argue where the dot, dot,
dot is pretty obvious. Here, this is damn
simple, it is a^kf(n/b^k). And, in Case 3,
we assume that the costs decrease geometrically
as we go down the tree. That was sort of backwards
to start with Case 3. Let's do Case 1, which
is sort of the other intuitively easy case.
In Case 1, we know that f(n) is polynomially
smaller than this thing. And we are sort of
changing by this very simple procedure in
the middle. I am going to wave my hands if
this is where you need a more formal argument.
I claim that this will increase geometrically.
It has to increase geometrically because this
f(n) is polynomially smaller than this one,
you are going to get various polynomials in
the middle which interpret geometrically from
the small one to the big one. Therefore, the
big one dominates because it is, again, geometric
series. As I said, this is intuition, not
a formal argument. This one was pretty formal
because we assumed it, but here you need a
bit more argument. They may not increase geometrically
but they could increase faster, and that is
also fine. So, in Case 3, you are dominated,
I mean you are always dominated by the biggest
term in a geometric series. Here it happens
to be f(n) and here you are dominated by n^(log_b(a))
with a bottom term, oh, Theta. Case 2, here
it is pretty easy but you need to know some
properties of logs. In Case 2, we assume that
all of these are basically the same. I mean,
we assume that the top is equal to the bottom.
And this is changing in this very procedural
way. Therefore, all of the ones in the middle
have to be pretty much the same. Not quite
because here we don't have the log factor.
Here we have a log to the k. We have n^(log_b(a))
times log to the kn. Here we don't have the
log to the k. So, the logs do disappear here.
It turns out the way they disappear is pretty
slowly. If you look at the top half of these
terms, they will all have log to the k. The
bottom half they will start to disappear.
I am giving you some oracle information. If
you take logs and you don't change the argument
by too much, the logs remain. Maybe halfway
is too far. The claim is that each level is
roughly the same, especially the upper most
levels are all asymptotically equal. Roughly
the same. And, therefore, the cost is one
level, here like f(n) times the number of
levels, h. And h is log base b of n. B is
a constant so we don't care. This is Theta(lg
n). And, therefore, we get T(n) = (n^(log_b(a))
lg^(k+1)(n)) times another log n. So, we get
[f(n)lg n]. That is the very quick sketch.
Sorry, I am being pretty fuzzy on Cases 1
and 2. Read the proof because you will have
to, at some point, manipulate logs in that
way. And that is all. Any questions? Or, you
are all eager to go. OK. Thanks. See you Wednesday.